Salut.
Bon dimanche à vous.
Je le dis doucement parce qu'en général le dimanche, je pense que vous regardez cette vidéo dans votre lit,
donc je ne veux pas vous brusquer non plus...
C'est le jour de l'explication de la semaine.
Aujourd'hui je vous explique quelque chose qui va vous permettre de bluffer quelqu'un, soit aujourd'hui soit dans la semaine.
La semaine dernière je vous ai appri à bluffer quelqu'un à l'aide d'une playlist
je vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo, j'ai une très très bonne annonce à vous faire à propos de ça.
Mais d'abord le tour du jour !
Vous pouvez le faire en même temps que moi, dans ces cas là prenez un papier et un crayon
et sinon vous pouvez juste regarder pour suivre la démonstration et regarder les explications à la fin.
Je vous ai concocter trois petites bulles: une rouge, une jaune et une verte.
Et à l'intérieur j'ai mis des chiffres. J'ai mis trois chiffres dans chaque bulle, de manière aléatoire.
Vous allez devoir composer aléatoirement trois nombres qui utilisent tous ces chiffres de la manière suivante:
Vous prenez un chiffre de la bulle verte, un de la bulle jaune et un de la bulle rouge.
Ca vous fait un premier nombre.
Pour le deuxième nombre, vous faites la même chose: choisissez un chiffre dans la bulle verte, un dans la jaune et un dans la rouge.
Mais attention, un chiffre qui a déjà été utilisé dans l'une des bulles, ne peut pas être reprit.
Et donc votre troisième nombre, vous le construisez avec le dernier chiffre de la bulle verte, le dernier de la bulle jaune, et le dernier de la bulle rouge.
Vous additionnez ces trois nombres ensemble. Utilisez votre calculatrice si vous voulez. Vous pouvez faire pause le temps de le faire.
Et soit vous calculez la somme soit vous appuyez sur le signe égal.
Et vous obtenez un nombre à vous maintenant. Un nombre aléatoire qui a été composé de la manière dont vous avez pioché, complètement aléatoirement.
Sachez évidemment que ce résultat je le connai déjà. Je sais déjà que vous de l'autre coté de la caméra, vous avez comme somme 1009.
1009, qui n'est pas du tout un nombre aléatoire, puisqu'il s'agit au moment où je vous parle, de mon nombre d'abonnés sur Instagram.
Et si vous voulez m'ajouter sur Instagram c'est Fabien Olicard.
Vous ne pouvez pas trouver plus simple...
On va passer maintenant à la partie explication. Juste avant d'aborder cette partie, si jamais ça n'a pas marché sur vous, c'est que vous avez fait une erreur.
Tout simplement ! Je ne veux pas lire dans les commentaires: "Mais non ça ne marche pas sur moi...!"
C'est pas possible, car c'est purement mathématique, ça ne peut pas rater.
Attention, ce n'est pas un tour en mode défi, c'est un tour que vous explique à vous pour le refaire à d'autres personnes.
La partie précédente c'est surtout la démonstration, pour que vous puissiez voir comment ça va.
Mais dans toutes les vidéos explications, où je parle de maths et que vous me dites que ça n'a pas marché sur vous, dans 100% des cas
c'est juste que vous avez fait une erreur mathématique.
Voilà c'est dit !
L'explication est très simple. Si on réfléchi, tous les chiffres qui a dans la première bulle seront les centaines, quoi qu'il arrive.
Tous les chiffres de la deuxième bulle seront les dizaines quoi qu'il arrive.
Tous les chiffres de la troisième bulle seront les unités quoi qu'il arrive.
Donc peu importe dans quel ordre on va construire les nombres, du moment que les centaines restent à leur place, les dizaines à leur place et les unités à leur place,
on aura toujours le même résultat, la même somme, quoi qu'il arrive.
Pour le faire à quelqu'un vous pouvez construire votre propre nombre à vous. Dans ces cas là vous commencez par créer une addition et ensuite vous allez faire vos bulles en fonction.
Il peut même y avoir 4 bulles, 5 bulles, 6 bulles...
Le mieux c'est de lui donner un papier à chaque fois qu'il utilise un chiffre dans une des bulles, il le barre, comme ça vous êtes certain qu'il ne le reprendra pas une seconde fois.
Et vous derrière le papier vous marquez le résultat en gros, comme ça quand la personne a fini son addition elle a juste a retourner la feuille et elle verra que vous
aviez prédit le résultat à l'avance.
Je vous mets dans les commentaires de la vidéo, un pdf téléchargeable que je vous ai préparé.
Si vous l'imprimez et que vous le pliez en deux, vous aurez d'un coté les trois bulles, et de l'autre coté la prédiction.
Comme ça vous n'avez plus qu'à imprimer, à plier et à faire le tour.
Il est pas beau le dimanche ?!
Je vous l'ai annoncé au début de la vidéo, je reviens rapidement sur le tour de dimanche dernier.
Il s'avère que j'ai eu une discussion avec Fabien Arcole, qui est un grand magicien, un grand créatif.
Et il m'a fait part du fait qu'il avait un tour avec une version similaire qui prenait ce concept là.
Quand je dis similaire, on parle bien de la base du concept parce que lui allait beaucoup plus loin.
Alors ce qui est assez drôle c'est que j'ai retrouvé son idée sans la connaître au départ, mais ça c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver quand on réfléchi
à un même sujet.
Sauf que moi je vous ai livré ça d'une version basique en fait, telle que ça m'est venu.
Lui, il a réellement travaillé dessus durant des années
il en a créé un tour qui est hyper complexe où tout est malin en fait, je ne suis même pas sûr que vous trouviez évident le lien entre les deux.
Et il l'a publié dans un livre qui s'appelle "Douceurs Mentales".
Donc c'est "Douceurs Mentales" de Fabien Arcole.
Si vous voulez aller beaucoup plus loin dans cet effet c'est lui qui a pensé à utiliser cette idée là, historiquement.
Il en a développé un truc de ouf. Merci Fabien de m'avoir fait découvrir cette version là c'est juste formidable.
Et deux Fabien pour le prix d'un du coup.
N'hésitez pas à me laisser un petit commentaire si vous faites le tour à quelqu'un pour me raconter comment ça c'est passé.
N'hésitez pas aussi à me laisser un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Parce que ça fait plaisir, ça encourage et ça c'est cool.
Si vous êtes nouveau sur cette chaine, bienvenue ! Pensez à vous abonner en cliquant là-haut.
Et passez un excellent dimanche. Rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !